and it's their work in science just like
the for all the tools you already know
will equip you to deal with this but
this is just so you don't panic when you
see it what am I doing this right
the goal is the goal is we want to get
this guy in a corner in a dark alley on
his own and then we'll get so beating
bad these kind of in two places at once
we want to collect them together so I
can do this in two steps or one just
because we're doing it as an example
I'll do it one step at a time
I'm gonna get all of the Kirby rules
together on one side so usually we end
up with the preview rule on the left
right that's just kind of a liqu
convention so therefore I'm going to get
rid of them over on the right and bring
them into the lab so what do I do what
operation in June is very good so I'll
subtract 2x from both sides 6x take away
2 X of course leaves you with I haven't
done any feeds of that plus 3 so I'll
just leave in there okay and then we
chose 2 X minus 2 X to get rid of you
right so now there's nothing and you can
see we do this over again we take a
problem looks a bit unfamiliar and we
just work with a week next size it until
it looks like something that we
afternoon and then we can proceed I
don't think you really need my hope to
go ahead if you suspect just for the
sake of it I should at this point
subtract something from both sides -
yeah and one more step looks just like
this right watch I can gather division
right because there's multiplication
happening to the officer
that gives you your solution ok now just
follow this before I leave this example
and they're very simple like look but
what is the problem is stuff you've seen
before and you'll really really cop into
that just before we leave it off how do
I know that this is the right on top how
could I actually yeah ok good I can read
you the whole thing I can substitute it
is the were looking for we did this did
a couple of hours
right I can substitute this here to here
and it should work do you ever the first
time we get solving equations solving
means find the value that works so let
me just quickly show you how to do that
because most people is seated li x
equals 4
that's all I'm going to try out okay
don't write this down and put it in red
so you see that it's wrong what most
people will do is they'll substitute
that directly into this almost like this
4 X plus 2 equals sign
4 times 4 2 x plus 18 right that time so
I just swapped everything there's a
substitute okay and I can evaluate this
natsu not of 6 times 4 is 24 so I'm
getting 2060 yeah
2 times 4 is 8 plus 18 is 26 and it
looks cool like it it does work right
I've got the same number on both sides
that's what I wanted right except it's
actually not what I want this doesn't
mean anything
let me prove achieve if my start by
something like this ok all right now
I've heard you know this is not sure ok
but I can do mathematical these with
this sound mathematical things with this
to end up with a statement like this for
instance I can just multiply both sides
by 0 like it's an equation right so I'm
doing the same thing to both sides so
that's meant to be okay and I get this
which is a true statement right so this
is true but that doesn't mean anything
with regard to this right there's
actually no connection in the logic is
completely floored right so this is a so
do you know what - no that's my do not
do not start in this way okay because if
you start by showing that they are equal
to each other then it doesn't matter
what you get and it's completely
relative want you calling them together
okay so now you can pick okay let me
show you how to do it properly the way
that it works is you want to show
remember it's it's that balance eating
right you want to look at one side show
what it is and look at the other side
separately and then show what it's and
this should be the same thing okay so
this is the way I'm going to demonstrate
I use an abbreviation LHS / f Tensei
okay rocket science right and now I'm
gonna substitute just over there right
so I'll go six times four plus two
I'm doing exactly the same maths all of
the same simplification this is still 24
plus two which is still replace it okay
and then I go for the other side the
right hand side it is one we say for two
times four plus 18 that's 8 plus 18
which is also 26 so now at this point I
can say finally with them separate not
assuming that they are equal to each
other because that was the first line I
wrote before now having done with them
separately I can say that's the left
hand side so it's true and you'll be
asked to show they'll give you a
solution and say can you prove that this
is actually the solution to dissipate it
and this is what they're looking to do I
hope you can see that actually the
number crunching is identical to what we
did when I said now wrong the difference
is the logical pieces are cooking
together so I would say